this is not the apocalypse you were
looking for pop culture has been
inundated with catastrophe porn for
decades none of it has prepared us for
our new reality and they have this
picture I guess it's like a zombie hand
coming out of the dirt but yes here's
what they say the shock itself is
shocking shouldn't we have been more
prepared hasn't culture been drenched in
catastrophe porn for decades the bomb
the breakdown the fallout the senseless
armies of shambling corpses all the
nightmares of dead generations sliding
on out of our screens for more than a
decade young and young ish people have
been living in anticipatory grief for
everything we know but somehow this is
different the idea of imminent
annihilating catastrophe has been part
of the collective unconscious for as
long as we've had one from the end date
of the Mayan calendar to the epic of
gilgamesh from the Genesis flood to the
Book of Revelations humans have been
haunted by the idea of the end of
everything for a very very long time
lately it's been our default popular
entertainment raised with the threat of
global warming in the teeth of a
financial crisis we set stunned and
exhausted watching our civilization die
on screen again and again more post
apocalyptic entertainment has come out
in the beginning of this century than in
the entirety of the last one the day
after tomorrow Zombieland The Walking
Dead the road children of men The Last
of Us the same story again and again
somewhere between wish fulfillment and
trauma rehearsal getting us used to the
idea that the future was canceled that
someday soon everything would collapse
and there would be nothing left and
nothing we could do about it
you know I love I love this I love this
yeah everybody who is you know watching
these these films and and pretending
like it would be fun yeah and the sad
reality was for now we're not roaming
the streets fighting over food
questioning the person in the gas
station asking them whose side they're
on earthing like that well we still got
we still got some time it's still we it
still feels like we have some semblance
of the norm I think we're closer than
we've ever been I agree with you
completely but for now it's like it's
the waiting I can't stand like either
pull the trigger on the collapse of
civilization or let us get on with our
boring routines
exactly you know III think we are
dangerously close close closer to it
than we've ever been but we mentioned
this before and I think it's interesting
that people like the glorify and
fantasize about the stuff yeah they
couldn't handle it and none of those
movies are like the after like the after
side of it you know it's like it's
always right when it's happening like oh
man we got to escape this volcano or
escape this tsunami wave or right you
know travel south and it's like during
the the you know everything hitting the
fan you know but then it's like okay
then what then what do you do you don't
have seeds you know what food you know
you got to find water somewhere but it's
like they don't those none of these
movies are show in that part like the
the real gritty part of life that is
like people starving to death yeah it's
not exciting eating each other yeah
eating each other they're right up you
don't understand how many people are on
this planet there's a lot of york new
york scary you know what the good thing
about this going kind of slow is people
getting out of New York
that's a good point because if the if
the collapse happened like overnight
people in New York would go on they'd go
full-on cannibalistic human humanoid
underground dweller in like days no more
food no more water people will be
swimming to like get out like if like
there any people who are gonna be
trapped they don't they don't know where
they can go and they're gonna be
desperate there's me fighting yeah
there's gonna be man dude New York is
gonna be literal hell like people with
guns looking for food and you have a
building in New York with you know 10 or
12 floors and like several apartments on
each floor and there me going
methodically through each through each
one you know certain you live in the
middle of nowhere you set up a couple
auto defense turrets right around the
property and you turn them on you go to
sleep everything's got now I'm kidding
but you you obviously have much less to
worry about when you're we started by a
lot less people yeah I would really love
to see what how people would respond to
a full-on apocalyptic scenario like how
you could simulate that to see how him
and humans react to it I don't know yeah
that's a good good point because there's
so much like the spectrum of like
humanity ending stuff could be anything
from I don't know so huge crazy solar
flare that completely you know
wrecks us a massive asteroid here's
supervolcano I'm just right here's some
advice a microwave is a Faraday cage I
think so jump in the microwave and close
it and you're safe put your phone so
actually know that people who do this I
don't know if this is legit but I know
people who have microwaves in their
basement and they have a brand new cell
phone in it why but why and so that when
the only light hasn't been used yet or
with like they preload apps and stuff on
it so when the EMP hits and all the
satellites are completely will have the
summation of human knowledge in your
pocket and you'll be king
oh I see you can download Wikipedia it's
like 7 gigs you can download survival
guides science how to make wire how to
start fire all that stuff I did get a
Survival Guide and I was scrolling
through and it's amazing the amount of
stuff that's on it think about how
powerful a calculator is just a
calculator yeah
like that was a premise for I think
there was like a Justice League like
series where I came over what the guys
name is savage sent a laptop just a
laptop regular old laptop from the like
2005 to himself during World War 2
ok and that simple bit of technology was
so powerful compared to the rest of the
world they were able to rapidly develop
crazy weapons and completely win and
it's dude if whatever happens having
having a smartphone yeah man so I know
people will like that I know some people
they have like you know a little nook in
their basement they'll put a microwave
in it they'll put like put stuff around
it and I'm like that might not be enough
you made more than that so what is the
advantage of having a phone with this
stuff loaded on it when you could have
like a survival book you could have both
what do you mean I mean the book use
putting a shelf your phone will the
battery will run out before to get a
solar panel I actually have a little
little backpack unfolding from goal zero
just like a you know you throw it out in
the Sun you plug in I have the little
battery pack you plug it in and could
charge my laptop what's my phone yeah so
that's great I don't know if I told this
story yet to you guys but during Occupy
Wall Street someone donated farmland I
tell you guys a story no I don't think
so
somebody donated farmland
and this is like hearsay so I know this
possum occupy people are gonna be like
that's no true or whatever but okay
whatever is what someone told me someone
donated farmland and a bunch of Occupy
Wall Street people who wanted to get off
the grid they didn't want to be a part
of society and capitalism and like
destruction of the planet so they went
to moved to a farm and guess how long
they lasted two days which I guess also
two days well yeah
cutting some slack is about two weeks
two weeks do we know that's impressive
is impressive well she she took my
answer so I thought I would have said I
would have said a week you know I didn't
you know I didn't you know I didn't last
that long because there's city dwellers
and they're used to not having to work
exactly they're used to not having to
work yeah I've known some people with
farms and I've actually done you done
some farm work and it's like you got to
get up early and start working you don't
get to like chill drink your coffee and
like relax and then write a blog you
write a blog on Brad Pitt's junk for
$50,000 Instagram feed it's like no no
you got to get up and do cuz like pretty
much the rule of thumb on a farm is you
finish one chore two more prop up yeah
and it never and never but this was this
was about survivability farming like the
idea was you got off the grid and you
were self-sustaining yeah and it's like
now do you understand why you like oil
so much yeah and why you don't want that
to go away
specialization it's it's it's it's
remark it's I find it so remarkable that
you know it's it's mostly people who
live in big cities who benefit the most
from fossil fuels and machinery
technology who are the ones complaining
about it yeah that's fine it's like yeah
it's really you know they say like if
this is that what people on the Left say
that from a point of privilege equality
looks like oppression it's like you have
you have no idea you have any idea what
would happen if you got your wish with
like shutting down fossil fuels like
Greta wanted to do yeah you you you
would be like you're no electricity so
no elevators right now you've got to
walk up those 17 flights of stairs right
like we use coal fraud to say it's like
the more than half of our of our like
Jersey well I think New York has nuclear
power but they want to shut that down to
never do dude these people would not
make it now you know what I was told
about the farm thing with occupy they
ended up leaving okay and I and I was
asking somebody who knew that like they
knew the people who were there
and they were like dude you have any
idea how insane it wasn't like oh I I do
of course I do this I'm not an idiot and
these people didn't realize they thought
living on a farm was gonna be like
sitting in a lounge chair like you know
chewing on a piece of straw reading a
book and getting away from all the noise
and life would be so much easier and
guess what it was really like yeah
getting your hands dirty waking up at
6:00 a.m. work and working until
midnight yeah and then going to bed you
get to eat a little bit in between but
when you stop working you don't have
food the best part was winter was it
coming and you got it you got and then
you got it you got a stock up a bunch of
the food store it for the winter
yeah of it properly and not only that
you're getting a horrible diet
throughout the winter yeah you're you're
not getting the vitamins you need your
food is imbalanced yeah they could not
take it yeah no that's not surprising at
all so what do you think these people
would do in a real apocalypse they would
starve nah what they I don't know do you
think they'd they're the ones that are
gonna go riding no no no oh yeah mate
riot yeah yeah but they're what they're
not gonna get very far
no they're not I mean there's because
there's plenty of people out there that
maybe not like our prepper status but
are prepared yeah they're prepared in
the sense that don't come into my house
yeah yeah could they've been like that
for a long time so once people are like
starting to riot they're gonna be like
okay don't come to my house
well this way now I will shoot you
because this was theirs there's two to
similar jokes one was a Dilbert comic
Scott Adams and Dilbert was like I think
it was he was asking about how the woman
is preparing and she goes I'm not I'm
just gonna go you know I'm preparing
like what are you doing and then she
basically said oh can you pick up hot
pockets so that when this all breaks
down I can get him like like the the
joke is someone posted this in the
superjet before they were like gun
owners want to thank all the people who
don't own guns for sucking up the
supplies for us when the apocalypse
happens right yeah here's the thing
we're seeing what we're seeing right now
is not it's not the apocalypse the
catastrophe that's what they point out
in the article but I'm curious we've
seen a lot of movies and the movies try
to pretend they know how people would
respond to an apocalypse no I don't
think we really do and everyone loves to
be that person though I would I would
never do that yeah I would have gone
left I would have stayed put oh I would
have done anything but whatever which
was just pushing the narrative of the
movie along you know it's like okay well
obviously they have to like a little bit
here's the truth man when when the
apocalypse does come the most brutal are
the ones who survive period period so
here's a little thought experiment I
tell people and I usually it's it's
weird to me that there's like a lot of
urban young people don't understand how
real life works and I think it's cuz
they've been insulated here's here's the
question I say to people I'll ask you
guys right now you're in the middle of
woods hundreds of miles from
civilization you're lost you have with
you a gun a rifle with with you know
limited rounds you have a small canteen
of water you have a little bit of food
all of a sudden off the distance at the
exact same time you notice another
person and they notice you they have the
exact same things that you have you
don't know where your next meal is gonna
be you don't know where you're going you
don't know where civilization is and you
see this person what do you do hmm but
and the the world's over already know
regardless of that let's say i doesn't
matter i do the equation you're you're
in the middle of nowhere in the in the
yukon lost you got teleported there who
knows okay and you've got a rifle yeah
you've got a little bit of food a little
bit of water the clothes on your back
you don't know where civilization is
you're it's it's cold you're trying to
find food shelter or whatever about a
hundred yards away you and another
person you both make out I contacted the
exact same time what do you do I would
probably say hello and then they yelled
back floor cab lop florica block Florida
whap [ __ ]
that'll do communicate very well you how
do you know they would speak English
well I would probably have a smile on my
face and I would wave then you know and
and probably because we have 100 like a
hundred yards away it's pretty far right
you know so it's like you know I would
probably lift my gun up you know as in
like a non-threatening manner like
holding my hands up with the gun visible
but not aimed at them as soon as you
raise your arm with the gun they lift
their gun up to shaking what do you do
well I probably duck behind a tree then
they see you moves as they're shooting
good thing I ducked behind a tree right
so this this this thought experiment
isn't meant to have in a correct
response okay it's to point out that no
matter what you do you can't expect how
someone else would respond and everyone
you know you know what like this is
really funny because one thing I often
hear from conservatives is like they
would have their hand properly on their
up and they'd hold up their hand and
they would move really slowly and they
would back away and leave
I hear from moderate people more stuff
like what you were saying like I try to
make contact you did I hear from people
on the left oh I'd go and greet them now
they can help me no I wouldn't trust
that I wouldn't trust them immediately
no no no but see if I was in an
environment like that you never know if
like if they were friendly then you're
two and not one
so your chances of survival it's to
increase so that's that's where my first
instinct would be is like I would rather
be 2 than by myself
and if they're friendly you know how do
you approach them if they don't speak my
language that's obviously gonna be more
difficult assume they do right you know
so if I yell hello and they or blah blah
blah blah Blake I'm all right you know
Florida blob yeah so so the challenge is
if you see this person you don't know if
they're starving yeah if they're angry
if they're scared you have no idea what
they're feeling they might see you and
see what you're caring and be like if I
take his stuff I'll live yeah why should
I bother with this person who might hurt
me I don't know them I don't they're
saying and so I you know I try to
explain to people that a lot of people
with these utopianist views think this
is how the world could work everyone
holding hands and singing and it's like
a rainbow and it's like not other the
reality is you take that scenario I gave
you scale it up to nation states yeah we
don't know the other is doing we don't
to give up our secrets we don't know
they're planning we don't know they're
gonna attack us and everyone needs
resources and so when you look at a lot
of how these countries are responding to
the controversy or the crisis right now
we don't know what China's internals are
they might you know for all we know
there's like some government official
who's like his his buttons are all
undone his tie is and he's drunk and
he's just like this is the end we're out
of resources our money is going up the
food supplies have stopped but don't
tell anybody
and so then you have these people saying
things like we need to be cooperating
with China they're a global leader
supplying us and they're ready to press
the button
yeah we just that's the problem that's
not that's what you know where you go
with conflict and war and stuff but also
for that scenario too it's like man I I
think it's a it's a guarantee that if
the apocalypse happened like liberals
liberal minded people would and you and
I say this because liberals tend to be
very passive like the actual liberals
I'll say it that they would die out oh
that's what you're about yeah yeah
totally what yeah yeah the reason is
though when I say liberal I'm talking
about people who like are gonna vote for
Joe Biden yeah they're clearly not
paying attention they don't know or care
about what's going on and then I really
haven't even heard him speak right
exactly
now the progressive for leftists yeah
many of these people are now actually
rather Pro to a yeah this has been a big
men say that aspect because of like with
an Tifa there have been a lot of you
know far love people who are like no we
demand our rights to own weapons and you
see and and they're they're they're all
you know groups that are considered to
be that or aligned like you know black
panthers for instance that showed up in
Virginia and all of the Liberty minded
people agree like we should have a right
to bear you know bear arms instead and
it's tough but the far-left ists I think
we'll survive the Communists the
authoritarians because they'll take what
they want they're aggressive you know
conservatives who are prepared and calm
and like methodical who are like not all
of them but enough of them will be
prepared and ready and then liberals
like your average liberal in this
country are gonna be sitting on their
hands confuse about what's happening
around them not believing it until
someone comes and takes their stuff yeah
or no no I'll tell you what like it's
gonna be in Manhattan and there's gonna
be like a picture this a dude with like
a beard and like wavy brown hair and
thick black frame glasses with a blue
button up shirt tucked into his khakis
as a leather belt sitting in his
Manhattan apartment watching the TV as
they say like the government has
collapsed we don't know this means then
the door gets kicked in and a bunch of
dudes come in and they have their guns
out and they're like where's the food
where's the food and he's like oh in the
cabinet and he's gonna be like what
what's happening and they're in taking
sperm they're gonna leave that he's in
have no food yeah those are the kind of
people it's like yeah yeah it's true
that's the apocalypse this is what they
want
yeah I don't know man but but you know
I'll go back to that last point and we
can jump to the super chance but like I
think we all you know we look at movies
to see how people would react but when
you look at movies like The Hunger Games
or like you know I don't know Dawn of
the Dead or something we don't take in
consideration the you know the political
alignment or like the the predictable
behaviors of certain areas like you know
areas of Utah for instance like more
Mormon areas will react very very
differently to New York very differently
yeah I'd be willing to bet to like
religious areas will survive very very
well oh yeah immediately because they
have a unifying you know reinforce yeah
right there's culture yeah whereas
people of all different random
backgrounds and ideologies will be
unified again by what you're in a city
and everyone's running around you're
gonna be I got to get out of here but if
you're in an area with like you know a
very religious community you're gonna be
like let's go see what everyone's doing
because you know everybody you could
this is one of the things that's
interesting about religion that we've
lost as the US has become more secular
is that people used to meet each other
at the church and talk about stuff
because I did this one you know when I
was growing up mm-hmm
how many people in New York get together
with their local community and talk to
each other and meet each other they
don't do it at all
no never no Luke the we are changing
dude has this video from a long time ago
where he went on the train and he was
like all of these people millions of
people every day on the train never
talked to each other at all yeah it's
dead silent yeah
these are everyone's on the phone listen
to music so look yeah it's true I'm not
saying like I'm personally not not
religious I'm not you know I don't read
the Bible or anything like that but I
think fact-based you have you have
people in New York who have no ties to
any community they don't know who lives
below them like when I lived in Brooklyn
I had no idea my dad's days neighbor was
same here heard him play music I'm gonna
talk to almost all of my apartments I I
didn't know anybody yep and and the
problem I mean there's people aren't in
places long-term either you know their
leader for a year maybe two but then
they find a different apartment with a
different friend or they broke up with
their significant other and they're like
have to find new places and they're like
constantly moving and that's like every
apartment you know right
it's like so that way since he is not
there and hits the fan what do you do
who do you trust you go downstairs knock
on your neighbor's door and you're like
we've never met before and he goes yeah
your stuff you have no idea or he's like
take my stuff please don't hurt me and
you're like why I didn't even ask you
for your stuff let's band together right
but I mean you know even it like when I
when I was growing up in Chicago we knew
all the neighbors everybody knew each
other New York yeah we lost that mm-hmm
so you know I was I was thinking about
it and I was reading something a while
ago that actually was not it wasn't
making this point but I realized it they
were talking about the water cooler the
Town Hall churches and it was talking
about social media censorship and the
threat we face because of it and one of
them was that because people used to
meet for church and it was like a very
very prominent thing in this country you
know decades and decades ago yeah that
conversations about politics were being
had as people were gathering and then
leaving they would also do events like
the when I was growing up the the church
we had on I think it was on Sundays I
don't know the payoff and they do this
but I think Sunday Mass was followed by
like a potluck what is it called unlike
everyone Branson like everyone brings
food and so me and my friends wouldn't
you know we're just little kids so we'd
be like dude it's so awesome you go
there and just like stand there for an
hour and then it's all the food we know
anything about the religious stuff what
people would be hanging out and then
people would talk and they'd in and and
they loved that there were kids there
like eating and like of our own volition
yeah all that's being lost in big cities
so yeah men let's grab this there you go
if you pocalypse happens there's a lot
of reasons to speculate as to why state
your average liberal is doomed
pay attention thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you